- Let's finish out
(audience applauding)
with one last story I found
on the pages of social media.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
All right, as we've talked
about much of this hour,
it can be difficult
for people in the trans
and non-gender-conforming
community to find safe spaces
to just kick back and be themselves.
That is one reason a
Brooklyn athlete decided
to open OutBox, a boxing gym
designed as an inclusive place
for anyone and everyone
looking for a good workout,
but particularly those
who identify as LGBTQ+.
We have him on the line right now,
watching on "NBC 4 New York."
Let's welcome Max, everybody.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
- What's up, Max?
- Hi. (chuckles)
Thanks-
- Oh, my God.
I love all the colorful gloves.
I'm so into it.
- Oh, yeah.
Kelly, we're a gay gym here, come on.
(audience laughing)
- All right, I love it, I love it.
So explain the gym to everyone.
- All right, well, we're
a trans-owned boxing gym
that centers the LGBTQ+ community,
particularly our trans
and non-binary members.
Our gym is completely non-gendered.
Everything from your first
experience at the front desk,
the bathrooms, locker rooms,
the language our instructors use,
we take gender out of everything.
I think that is a huge part
that keeps people out of the
gym, especially trans folks.
And all of our trainers are
queer, which I'm proud to say.
And we've become way more than just a gym.
We've become a community space.
We've had drag shows, we've had parties,
we've had karaoke nights,
blasting "Since U Been Gone."
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- So we have a special space here, so.
- Well, okay, so this idea came
from personal experience, right?
- It did, yes.
I was a competitive boxer
and I was about to go pro.
And the only problem is that
I was in the female division.
And I knew my whole life I was trans.
I just picked boxing over my happiness
for almost 30 years of my life.
After the pandemic happened,
like many, many trans people, honestly,
I was like, now is the time.
Everything's closed.
And I decided that I need
to do something for myself,
and I transitioned, and
that's when I realized,
wow, gyms and sports are
really uncomfortable spaces
and they don't want us here.
So during the pandemic
when everything was closed,
I decided to start hosting
LGBTQ+ boxing classes
in the park.
And week after week after week,
they were not only selling out,
there was people coming
out of the woodwork,
like more people week after week.
So I was like, I think
there's a huge need for this.
And that's when OutBox was born.
We opened up a brick-and-mortar
gym in Brooklyn
and we've been going ever since.
- Well, congratulations.
(audience applauding)
It's incredible what you did for yourself
and what you're doing for others.
Thank you so much, Max.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- Oh, thank.
(bell ringing)
Oh. (laughs)
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen at "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
- Oh.
(audience cheering)
That's awesome.
I did not know that.
Thank you.
- Absolutely.
Have a good one, Max.
(audience cheering)
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Patricia Clarkson,
(audience cheering)
Trace Lysette, Laverne Cox,
Jeff, Harley, and Kira.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.